how to stay aligned
so i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
yan long who wrote in to say i like your
videos even though your videos make
perfect sense when one is very busy that
person forgets
what you say in your videos i'm so glad
you brought this up
how to stay aligned with your goals with
this vision that you have for yourself
i don't think anybody has brought it up
and so i'm excited to be able to answer
this for you today
it's gonna be hard okay you've been
conditioned
your whole life you've been conditioned
to act behave
believe in a certain way and that as a
result
of listening to your friends your family
your your environment
your teachers your neighbors growing up
you have
limiting personal beliefs we all have
limiting personal beliefs you believe
this is
as much as you can do you have habits
that you're conditioned to do
that hold you back from being the person
that you could be
we all have these the step you've made
that a lot of people haven't made is
that now you've realized it and you want
to make a change
you start with wanting to make a change
the two ways to keep this consistent to
stay aligned
to stay focused i'm going to talk in
this video
number one is your environment you have
to look at your environment your
environment is holding you back
i am a new addition to your environment
okay i don't know how many videos you've
watched of mine i don't know if you're
consistently watching them or not
but i'm a little addition to your
environment that's saying
you need to change something i'm helping
guide you towards that person that you
want to be
but i'm only one person and i'm only i
don't know how often you're watching
these videos
you need to create a new
environment that supports you to
becoming the person that you want to be
supports you to be coming to doing the
things that you want to do
achieving the things that you want to
achieve it's not going to happen with
this environment right now that's
holding you back
so if you like watching my videos i do
two a day watch
two every day i can be a little jolt for
you
but that's not enough think about the
friends you hang out with
think about the movies you watch the
books you read the songs you listen to
the clothes you wear your daily routine
you have to make changes in all of that
your entire environment that builds you
up to become
that person that you want to be because
otherwise everything else is pounding
you back down
the same no you can't do this you can't
do this great thing
bam this is the person you're supposed
to be and you forget to take action
and you're so caught up in the busy
day-to-day okay change your environment
number two is take action
you can have the greatest environment in
the world and that's going to support
you but the end of the day you need to
take action
you need to start living your life like
that person
and it's not going to be easy and it's
not going to be
in an immediate change you talk about
changing habits you talk about changing
the way that you've been thinking and
acting and living
for your whole life okay a change like
that doesn't happen in a day or a week
it takes time it's a process
but it's a skill and you can learn that
skill just like you learn
any other skill i think about salsa
dancing
i love salsa dancing when people first
come to learn salsa dancing they spend
an hour learning the basics
you spend an hour learning the basics
and then they go home
and if they don't practice it they
forget it and they come back the next
week and they don't remember what they
learned
and they've got to relearn it again but
as you practice
and as you get better you get better and
better
and better the basic step becomes easy
and you look back is it basic step that
whatever i could do in my sleep give me
something harder i'm ready
they learned because they took action
and they practice
this vision you have for yourself this
ideal person you want to become
how does that person act start acting
like that person
today and you're gonna fall down and
it's okay you're gonna make mistakes
you're gonna forget you're not perfect
you're learning a new skill and like any
new skill to start you suck
right you suck at the beginning of
learning something new that's okay
it's to be expected but when you
practice and you commit to it and you do
something every day
to move forward on it pretty soon that
becomes your new habit
that replaces the old destructive habits
and you're doing more empowering things
and you're slowly becoming
that person that you want to become
that's how you stay aligned
that's how you stay focused because i
don't want you just watch a video
or read a book and say yeah wow that's
what i should do and then the next day
you wake up
and you forgot everything and you're
back to your old miserable life
change your environment and start taking
consistent
action towards your goals believe
for those of you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below let me know
what you think leave a comment guys the
comments mean so much to me i wake up
every day and i look at the comments
that's how i start my day
i love seeing your comments so please
comment below if you have a question for
me
put it below i'll make a video response
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel
see more videos like this thank you so
much i'll see you soon